[Music]
so
do
[Music]
uh
do
[Music]
two
here um watch out come on guys
follow me
[Music]
good
luke and the kids just got home with
another pig so we're gonna put them all
together and see if they get along this
is gonna be entertaining
[Applause]
oh look at him
don't open it no
he'll eat you
we won't be able to get him back
right in there
i'm riding with a pig
i don't know
we're gonna lift them up
legs or stick it in there
that would be safer
if you can lift it over
oh there we go
i got a friend for you guys
oh
[Applause]
they're excited
[Music]
maybe
oh my word
the sheep want to come
[Music]
oh there they come well
two are coming
[Music]
oh that's good
oh he's going under that's good
we've got two
they do not want to leave the area
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the wrong way
[Music]
why don't you just leave that open and
they'll eventually find their
[Music]
okay it looks like he's
oh look it looks like he's in now okay
so we got three
[Music]
got the compost now
it will not go past that border
[Music]
oh my god
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah
at least they're all together now
let them see you dump that yeah
i don't think they're looking though
well spotted one saw that
[Music]
there we go
oh they're all in
yeah
[Music]
quick
all right
[Music]
[Applause]